Hãy hãy mong tăng nắm một, thường viên Mỹ đã bỏ phiếu thông qua quy trình thúc đại trên rận.
Đối với nghị quyết về quyền phát động trên trang, với kết quả nắm mẹ a phiếu thuật bụng biệp bại thức trống và một phiếu trắng.
Tòn bỏ các thường y sĩ dân chủ cũng năng hị sĩ cộng ngoại ủng hộ động thái này,
mở đường cho các cuộc trên rận chính thức và bỏ phiếu, giờ gian dị ra chúng ta tới.
Như quên nhằm yêu cầu tầng thông đôi nân trang không được quy động của nội Mỹ,
cho các hành động quân sự nhằm vào video dưa lá, họ chên lãnh tổn nước này,
nếu chưa được có hội về trình, những người hộng hộ cho rằng,
hiện phát Mỹ chào quên quy định tham chiến cho có hội không phải giữ tổn thống.
Tuy nhiên, đẹp có hiệu lực, nghi quyết vẫn cần được hạ vĩnh Mỹ thông qua,
và phải đặt đa số 2,5 cải cả hạ vệ, nhằm vượt qua khả năng Mỹ tổn thống phủ quyết.
Fê cộng hoa phản đối cho rằng biếm bất sử tổn thống video dưa lá,
niệm của laz mà đu rô là hạt động thử thi pháp lợp.
Không cấu thành chiến dịch quân sự,
đồng thời khẳng định tổn thống Mỹ có quyền hàng đốc trong vai trò tổn tự lệ.